the e11 blaster han solos dl44 and even
boba fett's iconic ee3 the star wars
universe is full of weapons
that are more real
than you think and that's because they
kind of are in the process of bringing
the star wars galaxy to life george
lucas and production designer roger
christian opted for a world that felt
gritty and lived in a place that felt
dirty and industrial and naturally they
designed an arsenal to match that
aesthetic reaching into the real world
for their inspiration for their firearms
design i've come here to the royal
armouries to chat to keeper of firearms
and artillery jonathan ferguson about
the inspiration and impact of star wars
iconic loadout while they might be
famous for appearing in a galaxy far far
away
these weapons actually come from a place
a lot closer to home
[Music]
when star wars first graced the silver
screen in 1977 the arsenal that it
brought with it was in stark contrast to
what science fiction fans were used to
seeing
before star wars the majority of sci-fi
weapons were sleek shiny takes on
classic ray guns harking back to the 30s
and 40s serials of flash gordon and buck
rogers with star wars lucas wanted to
move away from the established aesthetic
of flash gordon and instead opted to
give star wars its own style and a key
element of this new style was lucas's
desire to stray away from the archetypal
ray guns when it came to building the
arsenal of this new sci-fi universe
so many things with the star wars
universe go back to
concept artist ralph macquarie and
although it's not immediately obvious
the same is true of the guns they're not
exactly front and center in his artwork
but if you look closely you will see
them
and although they're not identifiably
like mid 20th century military weapons
which is what they ended up being you
can you get a real sense of a chunky
sort of industrial little bit wild west
kind of an aesthetic and that's very
deliberate so george lucas himself
um macquarie is the concept artist and
then roger christian the set decorator
they they were all
you know they all got the concept it
created the concept it might have been
inspired by buck rogers like serialized
sci-fi tv but it was going to be more
grounded
with the drive to create a grittier
sci-fi universe george lucas brought on
board roger christian a young designer
who at the time was working on the 1930s
prohibition movie lucky lady christian
said that lucas didn't want anything in
star wars to stand out he wanted it all
to feel real and used a legitimate
lived-in universe designs and aesthetic
choices like this would bring a huge
depth of character to the world but the
challenge however was trying to realize
this vision with a budget of almost
nothing
christians said to work on the film
before it was even green lit by 20th
century fox paid out of lucas's own
pocket so as a result he had to get
creative iconic sets like the millennium
falcon interior and the death star's
trash compactor were cobbled together
from old airplane scrap metal bought in
bulk and assembled into backdrops that
would stand the test of time and this
idea of reusing and recycling old scrap
wasn't restricted to larger sets and
builds but was used to create smaller
props as well this led christian to the
crafty idea of reusing and repurposing
real working weapons in order to create
the arsenal of star wars
one of the first guns that christian
would show george lucas was in a shape
reminiscent of buck rogers sci-fi
classic xz-38 disintegrator pistol it
was a combination of real world german
mauser c96 broom handle and a handful of
spare parts combining to form one of the
most iconic firearms in the franchise
han solo's dl44 blaster
so han solo's famous blaster the dl-44
actually based on the mauser c96 that's
right so can you walk us through the
greebly's professional word that they
added i know you said they added a scope
but how did they sort of star
this for
for han solo the the production designer
visited visited the armorer and looked
for donor like host guns that they could
then attach stuff to and the easiest way
to change the outline of something
fairly iconic like a broom handle mauser
was to put a scope mount and a scope on
it now sacrilege for collectors this is
quite a nice
wartime commercial example they actually
had to drill a hole into the body of
this gun to then attach the mount for
the scope to then sit over the top of it
this was never meant to have a scope on
it but the bottom line was some sort of
scope some sort of muzzle attachment
which instead of being like a suppressor
or something was now a german mg81
muzzle
booster flash hider stuck on the front
they had to come up with a new chunky
welded on
barrel as well to support that and make
it not look too rubbish and moving
swiftly on from i suppose one side of
the alliance to the other is
boba fett's weapon of choice it doesn't
look like there's been a huge amount
changed in this weapon to
give boba his blaster there are a few
minor
tweaks cosmetic tweaks to it but i guess
because most of the audience wouldn't
know what this is which is a webby and
scott number one mark one flair launcher
break open shove in massive flare
close it up shoot it into the sky so
that kind of did as a generic laser
blaster just with a scope on it again to
give you that sci-fi look
but then for that was in obviously
empire strikes back but for return of
the jedi they gave it a whole new barrel
assembly with like ribbing and knurling
and more of a busy look to it with the
same basic gun as the base i think the
very iconic thing
is the sterling
which um went on to birth the e11
blaster
so i'll give you that version
and i
get to grab
the cool star wars wig
we can see a side by side of everything
that was done to
turn this into the empire's sort of main
infantry weapon of choice yeah which
isn't that much actually yeah we haven't
got the magazine fitted that obviously
that comes out here so is this one of
the
movie props that is a genuine st now all
of these were taken apart after filming
because they were a working armory they
hired stuff out so they took all the
grievances all of the stuff off but we
know because quite frankly the entire
inventory of sterling that baptism was
hired out for us for a new hope that
this is one of those guns and then it
was put back together sometime in the
90s with one of the original scopes one
of the original mags at least the same
stock of these plastic these were drawer
runners would you believe from a from a
hardware store i believe it's being cue
just stuffed in there to cover up the
cooling holes and make it look high-tech
and then for me the icing on the cake of
us having this in the national
collection of arms and armor is believe
it or not this slightly ropey looking
plastic box on the side because that's
not original to the gun but it was made
or acquired and added by lucasfilm when
they borrowed this and the rebel version
back from bapti
to redesign it for for force awakens oh
wow yeah so this was used as reference
so the full stop in its little movie
history is it was a reference piece to
create the f11d
the sort of rebooted version of the e11
so there we are beautiful piece of
cinema and firearms history that yep
good on sterling
of course the arsenal of star wars has
grown and developed in a number of
different directions since the very
first film back in 1977 and with the
ability to give fans the closest chance
to handle those classic firearms video
games have been at the forefront of that
development
star wars games have followed my love
for sci-fi and gaming across the years
as i'm sure they have for many others
from the 1995 first-person shooter star
wars dark forces to games like jedi
outcast and republic commando these
titles have formed some of my earliest
memories of being behind a virtual
blaster and across the decades
franchises and studios have brought
their own take to both existing star
wars weapons as well as creating their
own while star wars jedi 2 stuck pretty
close to the source material it did
allow players to get their hands on some
more iconic offerings like the wookie
bowcaster
and its rendition of the imperial e11
still had the recognizable form of the
sterling even with these early 2000s
graphics
republic commando helped popularize the
idea of interchangeable weapon systems
where the clone's default dc-17m weapon
system was able to reconfigure into
standard blaster assault rifles
compact sniper rifles
or even an anti-armor grenade launcher
this idea actually played nicely with
both other games and movies within the
franchise as we would go on to see other
configurable weapons like the rebel a280
series of blaster rifle
in terms of the balance between staying
true to the source material and creating
fun video game versions of these iconic
sci-fi weapons the games that do it best
in my opinion are dice's rebooted
battlefront titles the battlefront games
do a great job in making sure the vast
majority of their arsenal is fun to play
with as well as true in spirit to the
trilogies in which they come from and
for a game that plays out across
multiple generations of star wars lore
each with their own unique style and
flavor that is no mean feat
classic weapons like the t21 and the dlt
19 wonderfully match up to their
in-movie counterparts as well as keeping
the aesthetic of their inspiration in
this case the lewis gun and mg34 these
are weapons that we see used in the
movie not uncommonly but game designers
tweak and toy with what they are capable
of to make them more suited to different
roles classes and applications but in a
way that their operation is still close
enough to the source material yet far
enough removed that each one feels like
its own beast
there are also plenty of weapons in the
star wars universe that don't get their
share of the limelight in tv shows or
the movies but get a second life in
video games weapons like the scatter gun
first seen in an episode of the clone
wars or the jawa c87 ion blaster first
seen in the very briefest of shots
disabling r2d2 in a new hope while both
these weapons appear in blink and you'll
miss the moments on screen they are both
common sidearms in battlefront 2 and
they both still retain that real world
weaponry dna that christian and lucas
instilled in the franchise back in the
mid 70s the scatter gun taking cues from
the spaz 12 and the ion blaster from a
cut down lie enfield rifle
video games are always going to be an
integral part to the star wars fandom
but the challenge for developers working
on star wars games is balancing the
players expectation of these iconic
weapons while also creating something
new and exciting for players to play
around with so the big challenge for any
large franchise like star wars you have
to extrapolate from what everyone knows
what's established by say the first
movie and populate that universe with
more stuff the real world is is varied
and if in a sort of space cowboy setting
like star wars you're going to come
across lots of different weapons so
you're going to have to invent wholly
new types of weapon that fit the world
so it's a real challenge for i think for
developers to
meet expectations but also take things
forward i think star wars games have
mostly been successful with that the
first thing that comes to mind is the
briar pistol from dark forces the the
original star wars first person shooter
that never been seen before in a star
wars movie and even though that wasn't
based directly on a known world war two
guns say as as most star wars guns do
somehow it's still fitted so they made
they took a slight gamble there and
introduce something new and now you'll
see that blaster in other star wars
media as well so it's established itself
despite changes and challenges the
legacy of the original trilogy's arsenal
of firearms lives on they broke the
mould for sci-fi designs away from the
conventional ray guns of the 30s 40s and
50s and paved the way for more grounded
sci-fi weapons like the pulse rifle and
deckard's sidearm from blade runner star
wars showed that movies can create rich
and original science fiction universes
by pulling just a little bit from our
own reality
and the prequels sequels and spin-offs
to one degree or another still take
notes from those cobbled together guns
and spare parts that were brought to
life in the originals from the m60
machine gun in rogue one
the g36 assault rifle in the last jedi
or even din jaren's 19th century bergman
1894 pistol in the mandalorian
i believe that the arsenal of star wars
will always be at its best when it's
rooted in our reality
and for the team that tried to build
their sci-fi vision with an extra no
budget a box of prop weapons a pile of
scrap and some old airplane parts that's
a pretty impressive legacy
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
week's episode of loadout if you enjoyed
please like the video and subscribe for
more and of course you can reach out to
me at a regular dave or let me know down
in the comments below what else you'd
like to see an episode on if you want to
see more video game firearms content
then you can watch our previous series
of this show or check out our weekly
series of expert reacts where i show our
friends the royal armories a slew of
guns to break down until next time i've
been your host dave dewitt thank you
again for watching and i'll see you in
the next episode
[Music]
[Music]
you